and say community cannot hear me Tiamo
Paola it's perfect
okay so this is our lesson let's yeoman
Dumas pathology so I asked you all fun
I'm here famine common
how are you Coleman stop it is that you
improving her oh yeah that's good
I'm asking all of you plural some say
you plural
stop it boy kuma started even asking
only one of you yeah comment
sign-u single and this is very good
friends or family it's an informal way
mr. if well for example if we were in
formal relationship then I just say shut
up like stop instead of three different
versions for one single sentence that in
English translates into how are you I
want to notice another theme we're using
the verb to stay style not the verb SF
which means C so do you learn a little
bit more about these communications and
about the difference between static to
stay and si is to be so when I asked you
come you started some of you said babe
right
and to stop him well you're always
feeding us Dominici sometimes you can
say not Ramallah maybe you can say kuzhi
kuzhi maybe you were sick then you could
say tomato
you know he's like I'm yours
when we used thin we mean I felt good
I'm good right when it is an answer if I
say that the pizza is good I can say
lucky sucked at bailing my shame yes
when you like something when you're
eating in your mouth is full you do like
this
everybody's I'm crazy I really like it
like wanna have two words and I wanna it
was masculine whatever so this is an
adjective and this is an adverb in
English both of them but each other
perfectly attention to the difference
when you see it after they did when it's
fantastic Warner Bona and so on of G so
is like yes
oh gee pushing out left so we're going
to do things a little bit differently
first base and then we come back and we
started even before